This lacy stitch pattern is an easy one
to work and remember,
with no cheat sheet needed.
Cast on a multiple of five
stitches plus two.
For my scarf, I cast on 25
stitches plus two for the edge.
To keep the edges neat.
There are two needles and work on each
side with no transfers over these needles.
I started by knitting two rows and ended
with the carriage on the right.
That's not critical,
but be consistent for your entire scarf.
The stitch pattern consists of
transferring stitches to a center needle.
First, transfer to the right,
knit two rows, and then transfer
to the left and knit two rows.
Alternating the transfers
creates the lace.
To
make things easier, I marked
my needle bed with a dry erase pen.
You can also use a pencil.
This made it a no-brainer as
to which needles were
the center needles each time.
after you work your transfers,
make sure the empty needles are in working
position before you knit the next row.
Do this on every transfer row.
Now don't get lost if you
need to take a break.
Either keep track of your row counter,
for example, transfer right on row two,
transfer left on row four,
right on row six,
left on row eight, or read your knitting.
This is my center stitch.
Looking below, I can see the large
eyelet from the previous transfer.
This tells me that I'm
transferring right on this row.
That's it.
A pretty and easy stitch
pattern with beautiful results.
When you've knit your required number
of rows or you're running out of yarn,
knit two rows plain and bind off loosely.
Block your scarf and enjoy.
Happy knitting.